[Music]
try and do some good
before you find yourself here
[Music]
Finbar morphine I have something else
for you in a week or so I've been
thinking it's been a lifetime of poor
choices I've made
so many people have you killed
altogether
more to me than this
I'd like folks to see it
trying to find a friend
what's the name
Finn bear Murphy has done something
Unforgivable
you can give him a message
we tear right through this God forsaken
place
no one will be safe
[Music]
go
this thing's got to be a sinner first
Tony
hurry
people will come people are a lot worse
than me
so love me no choice then by Murphy's
going towards I'm not missing out all
the fun
I've seen enough killing for a lifetime
thank you peace
thank you